[Musique]
après avoir parcouru 6000 km lors du 4L
Trophy en 2022 les Sisters en vadrouille
Prescilla et Marie deux amis ont décidé
de repartir à l'aventure l'objectif le 4
Alpe cet été 750 km en 6 jours de
Bourg-Saint-Maurice en Savoie à Menton
dans les Alpes-Maritimes en fait on
voulait vraiment pas comme je disais
avant laisser la 4L au fond du jardin et
plus la toucher peut-être office c'est
un souvenir mémoire pour nous enfin
c'est une des meilleures expériences de
notre vie et quand on est rentré on
pouvait juste simplement pas s'arrêter
là donc on a décidé de repartir pour le
Défi sportif et pour le défi humanitaire
et tous les fonds de ce raid
humanitaires reviendront à l'association
never again qui lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et les
inégalités entre les hommes et les
femmes top départ le 30 juillet mais
pour être prête certaines vérifications
s'imposent on a plein de choses à
revérifier parce que les elles ont pris
assez cher dans le désert au 4L Trophy
donc tout ce qui est déjà dans la
direction le train avant etc tout ça il
faut revoir parce qu'avec les cailloux
le sable ça on a tous ça encore à revoir
et au niveau du moteur il faut qu'on
fasse des vérifications pour tout ce qui
est le système de refroidissement parce
que on va elles vont avoir très chaud on
va être très haut en altitude on va y
avoir des grosses montées donc ça va
être très très dur pour pour la 4L il
faut qu'on ait toute la puissance
possible que le moteur il soit au top et
la 4L ou la titine comme elle la
surnomme et déjà bien peaufinée on a
installé en bois un système qui
permettait de mettre des matelas dessus
pour pouvoir dormir la nuit parce que
des fois les nuits elles étaient assez
froides les gens qui nous ont fait des
dons nos proches etc et donc ce qu'on a
fait pour les remercier c'est que sur le
capot on a écrit tout le tous les
prénoms de toutes les personnes qui nous
ont aidés financièrement nos proches etc
nos amis des montagnes des lacs des
falaises voilà ce qui attendent les deux
jeunes filles qui sont imp atientes de
partir mais pour ça elles ont encore
besoin de quelques fonds et de sponsors
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
internet juste en dessous
[Musique]